as anxiety about the corona virus grows
president trump drew criticism from some
health experts for comparing the illness
to the common flu he tweeted yesterday
quote so last year 37 thousand Americans
died from the common flu at this moment
there are 546 confirmed cases of corona
virus with 22 deaths think about that
dr. Jon LaPook is here to answer
questions about the difference between
the flu and the corona virus John good
morning good morning is it fair to
compare the flu in the corona virus well
there's no doubt that the flu is deadly
and how many times have I been there and
saying tens of millions of people get it
every year tens of thousands of people
die get the flu shot and do all the
hygiene that we're talking about this is
on top of that and we're talking about
really different things so here's the
difference the flu as bad as it is as
deadly at it as it is
come spring come rain or shine we know
this season's gonna start to go down and
it's gonna stop there's a flu vaccine
there's treatment like Tamiflu with the
corona virus it's a new novel
coronavirus so calm warm weather we
don't know what's gonna happen it may
die down it may not there's no vaccine
there's no treatment and unlike the flu
this is important unlike the flu where
from past seasons we may have a little
bit of immunity left over this is novel
its new nobody has so the food's been
around we know what it is we've got some
remedies yes virus is new it's uncertain
people worried as a result ate and the
stock market hates uncertain what are we
people here what do we know about the
death toll it's not tens of thousands a
year because it hasn't been around for a
year but where is it headed based on the
mortality that we know I think it's too
early to tell that and I'll tell you why
we're seeing mortality rates that are
going from very less than one percent in
South Korea where they're testing a lot
of people almost two hundred thousand to
four percent something like that in
other areas and I think a lot of it has
to do with how extensive the testing is
and where they're catching the people if
you catch the people you're not doing a
lot of testing and you catch them when
they come in when they're sick the
mortality rates going to be higher if as
appears to be happening in South Korea
you're testing hundreds of
of people and you're getting them when
their symptoms are very very low or
maybe they don't even have symptoms
mortality rates gonna be much lower less
than 1% in South Korea for folks out
there I mean someone coughs someone
sneezes they're like coronavirus so how
does a person know the difference
between the flu and the symptoms of
coronavirus you know they may not they
can overlap so you know the flu that you
have have you ever had the flu Michelle
oh yeah I'd have one time every muscle
in my body ache you have that muscle
ache and you just you have a high fever
but you can have some of the same
symptoms you can have a coffin you can
certainly have fever shortness of breath
you can have with both so that's why
these tests are so important and we now
are saying the we're being promised that
millions of these are going to be here
in the next few weeks I think that's
gonna change things a lot we're gonna
see and I want to immunize people about
one thing about these new testing as we
do more testing you're gonna see you may
likely see the numbers really
dramatically rise in the United States
on the one hand we don't want to see it
widespread but it's very possible that
that's what's going on and when people
see these higher numbers then the
mortality rate is gonna drop right
because you can have a lot of people who
have minor symptoms and who's the drop
mortality rate might be reassuring don't
be rattled by the higher don't be
rattled by the higher numbers which
really I want to I mean the issue is we
haven't we just haven't tested we did we
don't know and it's you know it's like
it's like flying blind right now for me
as a doctor people come in I got have
had so many phone calls the last couple
of days about this we need the testing
all right dr. Jon LaPook thank you very
much